so you've been learning a language for a
while now and you finally have a chance
to visit a country where that language
is spoken what do you do how can you
approach your trip to ensure that you
can use that time in country to learn as
much as you can all while having an
amazing time hi I'm Lucas I'm a Language
Coach who speaks 14 languages and on
this channel I help people learn foreign
languages faster more efficiently and in
a fun way in this video I'll show you
how I squeeze every ounce of language
learning juice out of my travels so that
you can do the same let's Dive Right In
shall we before I share my five tips for
maximizing your language learning while
traveling let me preface my advice by
saying this if you want to use your
travels to expand your language skills
in a serious way I recommend obtaining
at least an A2 or high beginner level in
that language first though it is
possible to apply the tips I'm about to
share to a brand new language it's not
something I would advise in fact the
lower your skill level the more
difficult it is to learn the language
while also using it to navigate your
day-to-day life at the same time so try
to learn as much as you can before going
to the country you will not regret it
tip number one cultivate your curiosity
perhaps the most important strategy for
learning a language while abroad is
simply to be as curious as you possibly
can you're about to be in a place where
the written and spoken language you're
learning is everywhere on signs and
buildings in books newspapers and
magazines and a whole lot more heck when
you're around native speakers the
literal air will be thick with your
target language because of that it's
quite literally in your best interest to
act like a sponge and try to absorb as
much of that natural authentic language
as you can so make it a habit to read
nearly every bit of text you see road
signs restaurant menus brochures books
and so on take particular advantage of
bilingual resources for tourists which
typically come in English or another
language commonly spoken by tourists and
the local language similarly build a
habit of constantly listening even to
people who are not speaking directly to
you if you're in a well-populated area
like a city you're likely surrounded by
dozens of people speaking the local
language at any one time if they're
speaking audibly enough that you can
hear them listen see what you can
understand even if you can only hear a
few words here and there remember to use
common sense with this one you do not
want to listen so conspicuously that
people can accuse you of eavesdropping
but if you can clearly hear what they're
saying without specifically going out of
your way to do so then there's little
harm in listening in order to test your
skills tip number two carry a language
learning notebook with all the reading
and listening you're going to be doing
after following my last bit of advice
you will need to know what to do when
you hear or read something in your
target language that you might want to
use yourself
what do you do in that situation the
answer is simple write it down in your
language learning notebook
what notebook you ask oh just the pocket
size notebook that you'll carry around
with you constantly during your travels
a sturdy but inexpensive soft cover
notebook that's small enough to keep you
in your pocket pocketbook or travel bag
along with maybe a small pen or pencil
you can find many such notebooks through
a quick online search but if you want a
few recommendations take a look down in
the description box I've left some links
for you whatever portable notebook you
choose its purpose will be to hold all
of the most useful and relevant words
phrases expressions and other
information you encounter during your
travels as I said earlier you should be
reading and listening a lot as you
travel you certainly do not have to use
your language learning notebook to write
down all or even most of what you hear
but you should use it to store and
Safeguard any bit of language that you
feel inclined to incorporate into your
own language use by writing down notes
and regularly reviewing them you will be
able to gradually memorize these words
and expressions and later even work them
into your active speaking and writing
but none of that happens if you don't
start by writing in your notebook so
remember to carry it with you no matter
where we go tip number three practice
common and expected situations in
advance as you travel you'll find that
there are some situations that will come
up repeatedly time and time again for
example you'll probably have to get used
to ordering food at a restaurant
purchasing a train ticket at a ticket
counter or talking to a taxi driver so
he can get you to your proper
destination repeating scenarios like
these provide a great opportunity for
you to practice and hone your language
skills in a very direct targeted way so
as you try level take note of the
scenarios you repeatedly find yourself
in or you expect that you will find
yourself in multiple times if you expect
to do something a lot it pays to
practice and refine your language around
that situation so you can improve
quickly for example if you go to the
same coffee shop in Rome every morning
to grab an espresso and a quick snack
write down the questions the Barista
asks to take your order then the next
time you order practice your refined
version you will find that you'll be a
lot more prepared and comfortable and
your interactions will be much more
authentic as a result tip number four
hang out with locals one of the best
ways to learn a language while abroad is
perhaps the most obvious by spending as
much time as possible with native
speakers there's quite simply no better
and more authentic source of language
than a person who speaks that language
as his or her mother tongue everyone you
meet is a potential Treasure Trove of
every source of language knowledge you
can imagine pronunciation vocabulary
grammar slang culture you name it you
can learn about it from a native speaker
even if the person you're interacting
with has no desire or ability to teach
you their language you can still learn a
near infinite amount just by observing
what they say how they speak and the
Limitless ways in which they use their
language to express themselves now you
might be thinking okay Luca I get it you
can learn a lot from natives but how can
I actually find native speakers to hang
out while I travel
that's easier than you might think
nowadays there are a wide range of apps
and online platforms that anyone can use
to easily meet people and make new
friends even when abroad in my opinion
the best place to start is with language
learning mobile apps like hellotalk and
tandem these apps are Community
platforms where native speakers and
Learners can easily find each other
interact and even meet in person but
you're not just limited to language
learning apps either online platforms
like Meetup and even bright are great
ways to discover groups clubs meetings
and other in-person events that are
happening nearly anywhere in the world
you'll have more options in big cities
of course but no matter where you're
traveling these sites are worth a look
last but not least you can also use
dating apps as an effective way to
connect with others as you travel I'm
talking about apps like Tinder Plenty of
Fish Bumble and Grindr just to name a
few most people use these apps to find
romance but if that's not what you're
looking for you'll find that there's
usually an option to look for friendship
tips rather than relationships if the
other options I've shared do not appeal
to you definitely give dating apps a try
once you've found a native speaker to
hang out with the rest is relatively
easy grab some coffee go to a movie
visit a museum or attend a local event
the sky's the limit really just spend
time with the person do your best to use
the language and then also try to absorb
as much a language as you can from them
doing that has helped me make huge
strides in many of my best languages so
I highly recommend it tip number five
hope for the best but prepare for the
worst this last tip here is primarily
about managing expectations while we
often hope that our travels and language
learning experiences will go as
pleasantly as possible the reality is
that things often go wrong you might not
understand someone speaking to you or
they might not understand you you might
stutter or get flustered when it comes
time to speak people might even be rude
to you when you make mistakes a lot more
can go wrong than just that but you get
the idea not everything will go smoothly
all the time rather than run from that
fact the best thing to do is prepare
yourself for it mentally well in advance
of your trip things will go wrong you
will make mistakes but you will be okay
as I always say mistakes are an
inevitable and unavoidable part of the
language learning process so the best
thing to do is embrace them and see them
as stepping stones on the path of growth
and language Mastery okay those are my
five tips for maximizing your language
learning while traveling abroad
[Music]
to recap these tips are as follows tip
number one cultivate your curiosity tip
number two carry a language learning
notebook tip number three practice
common and expected situations in
advance
tip number four hang out with locals and
tip number five hope for the best but
prepare for the worst if you do these
things while traveling abroad in a
country where your target language is
spoken then I can guarantee that you
will learn a lot a ton more than you
ever could learn from staying at home
okay that's all for now if you'd like to
learn additional tips and strategies for
learning a language while traveling
abroad then check the description box
for a link to an article that goes even
more in depth on this awesome topic
thanks for watching and as always happy
language learning